il a assuré la protection rapprochée de
la chanteuse taylor swift ou du
basketteur américain de nba kobe bryant
garde du corps de profession ahmed
bouche icare a débuté dans les métiers
de la sécurité à l'âge de 18 ans il
s'oriente ensuite vers la protection
rapprochée en passant plusieurs
certifications à l'étranger ce qui lui a
permis d'assurer la protection de
plusieurs stars ont fait ça se fait du
bouche à oreille beaucoup du bouche à
oreille non comment appeler parce que
j'avais un bon profil parce que j'ai été
formé aux états unis en angleterre et au
canada aussi en france qui m'a permis
d'avoir ce week-end carte pour aller ce
jour-là ahmed est venu s'entraîner au
parc sportif philippe cousteau de la
verrière endurance agilité musculation
l'objectif est de maintenir une
condition physique
pourtant au regard du corsa pas évident
quand on a des obstacles donc il faut
toujours se préparer pour ça donc c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui j'anticipe tout
le temps à m'entraîner tout le temps que
je me suis vraiment aussi les risques
mois déploie le kevlar et owendo nous
protège la personnalité son enfance
ahmed la passer à la verrière il a
notamment joué au sein du club de
football de la commune
comme un signe du destin il occupait le
poste de gardien de but
ça m'a beaucoup apporté surtout avec des
personnes qui étaient autour de moi qui
m'ont beaucoup conseillé
après tout dépend du domaine donc
beaucoup conseillé sur sur la vie quoi
en plus de sa profession ahmed toufiq a
fait partie de l'équipe du week-end des
médiateurs sociaux de la verrière un
engagement pour sa commune son rôle
échanger et discuter avec les jeunes des
trois quartiers de la ville pour
développer le lien social
l'important c'est déjà de faire le lien
avec tout le monde on fait entre les
jeunes les jeunes et les moins jeunes
entre la police et les jeunes dans celle
des fois dans la vie c'est pas facile
mais voilà on peut toujours s'en sortir
avec les bonnes personnes et on peut
être toujours bon conseiller
même si des fois dans des familles ça
peut pas le faire où chaque personne
comme des jeunes sont mal orientés donc
nous on est là pour ça pour les aider
les
orientaux pour ahmed la médiation est
complémentaire avec sa profession dans
le contexte de la crise sanitaire
difficile de trouver de l'activité dans
la protection rapprochée
le verrier roy espère des jours
meilleurs avec en perspective la coupe
du monde de rugby en france en 2023 et
les jeux olympiques de paris en 2024